so this study shows that uh they
surveyed 10 000
millionaires it's the ramsey solutions
conducted the largest survey of
millionaires ever 10 000 participants
and the top five careers of people who
become a millionaire they have engineers
they have accountants they have
management and they have attorneys there
are four of the five what do you think
the fifth one is so engineer accountant
management attorney the fifth one is one
you would not expect
that is the highest career or the
highest concentration of millionaires in
a single uh
uh
occupation sales people
no agriculture no lawyers doctors
uh so attorneys are interested but yeah
engineers accountants management
attorney and teachers
and he was telling me he was like yeah
one of the top five professions for
people to become a millionaire is a
teacher and i think most people are
conditional yeah well most people are
conditioned to think hey
teachers don't get paid a lot of money
they get paid 40 50 60 000 depending on
if it's public or private but they know
math where they are
well even better than that is they're
super disciplined
the person that ends up becoming a
teacher from like a psychological
standpoint they're not trying to go buy
a yacht right they're not trying to go
buy the the ferrari they usually end up
being uh somebody who hey i want to go
to work i want to i want to teach people
they live within their means they have
kind of financial discipline and they'll
become your millionaire and so it makes
sense you know you think engineers uh
and uh and management or attorneys they
make a lot of money they have kind of
high top-line
income and so can they become a
millionaire but when you look at
accountants like okay they understand
accounting like they'll figure it out
but teachers i think is like really
interesting because it completely
dispels one of the things that most
people think is true is like oh you have
to make a ton of money most teachers
really don't make that much money right
but it is one of the top five careers
for millionaires that makes me feel good
hearing that why
that teachers are doing well financially
because it's always been the narrative
someone just said in the comments
it's cheating because they can get
summer jobs like no that's not how this
works
they have two jobs
that's an all-time comment so i just
quickly searched the average salary of a
teacher and salary.com has between forty
thousand and seventy thousand zip
recruiter has it between sixteen
thousand and forty thousand uh and then
glassdoor has between thirty thousand
and sixty thousand so let's call it
somewhere between you know twenty to
maybe sixty or seventy thousand dollars
uh to be a public school teacher and uh
we know that thirty three percent of
millionaires like john said have never
made more than 100k in a single year um
and one of the top five professions to
become a millionaire as a teacher so
it's pretty damn cool when you start to
understand so what's the thought process
behind that you can either make a lot of
money or you can be really disciplined
well the holy grail is you do both right
is you have incredible earning potential
you make a ton of money and then on top
of that you're financially disciplined
so you actually end up getting there
faster you end up compounding it and
whatever but even if you don't make a
lot like again think about it if you if
you start working at the age of 22 right
and you get paid 50 000 a year
i'm not a mathematician but you only
need to work 20 years and now you've
been paid a million dollars of top line
income now you've got expenses you've
got to pay taxes you got to do all this
stuff so but you can also invest you can
invest you can do all this stuff right
but like you've already been paid a
million dollars by the time you're 42
years old and you only make a 50 000 a
year and you're a teacher so what
happens if you become financially
disciplined and let's say that you can
save a big portion of that well okay now
you've been working for 30 years then 40
years right like at some point by the
time you hit retirement if you've been
paid 50 000 a year you literally made 2
million bucks
in top line revenues it's to kind of
bill's point it's not how much you made
it's how much did you keep yeah right
and so if you just put let's say uh uh
double that right now it's not 50 it's
100.
well in 10 years you've literally made
a million dollars in top line revenue
yeah and this applies
some people in the comments are are
giving us a hard time because it's we're
it's like we're saying teachers are
millionaires and and the point is really
yeah they are no they they literally are
it's one of the top that's what the
stats says
i didn't make it off
like like literally teachers are
millionaires like it is one of the top
five professions to become a millionaire
in the united states but but it's it
could be applied to anyone at that
income level that's my point oh for sure
yeah i'm not saying that they're getting
paid a million dollars a year that's how
become a millionaire i'm saying that
they likely have uh a propensity for
living within their means more so than
anybody else like we all went to school
i don't remember a teacher showing up in
a corvette
right like i don't remember them
spending like lavishly frankly most of
them kind of showed up to school and
they probably were wearing the same
clothes they'd worn for a while and like
it was just like that's just what they
do they go to school they teach you know
uh during the school year and then they
leave well to the point about the math
you know they have to count what
resources they have because there's
little of it right so they have to count
in order to feed themselves
where i think people get into trouble is
especially in business and you start
selling products for example to your
point you can look at the revenue line
item and you can say oh my god look at
how much money i'm making and that
revenue can be very deceiving right so
um it doesn't surprise me hey guys bang
bang thanks so much for watching the
best business show today and don't
forget to check out our partner sofi
they make all this possible they're a
super app that lets you save spend
borrow earn and invest all from one
single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofi
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.compomp
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
sofi.compomp and make sure you come back
and watch more of the best business show
we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help